the Iowa caucuses are 368 days away and
the potential field of Democratic
candidates is quickly growing the mayor
of South Bend Indiana Pete Budaj is
launched a presidential exploratory
committee last week the 37 year old has
spent seven years in charge of the city
he grew up in he's a Harvard graduate
he's a Rhodes Scholar he's known as
mayor Pete
he was also deployed to Afghanistan for
seven months with the US Navy Reserve
and he's got a new book out
it's called shortest way home one
mayor's challenge and a model for
America's future the mayor is here for
an interview you'll see first on CBS
this morning Mayor Budaj is welcome good
morning how's the great state of Indiana
bit chilly but other than that we're
getting very cold indeed I also wanted
to start first and say our condolences I
know your father passed away on some day
thank you appreciate that I know he
would have been watching if he could
well thank you for being here so you're
37
your town you represent a town of a
hundred and two thousand people did I
get what qualifies you to be present in
the United States well for starters the
experience I know that I'm the youngest
person in this conversation but I think
the experience of leading a city through
a transformation is really relevant
right now look I've got more experience
in government than the President of the
United States I've got more years of
executive experience than the vice
president and I have more military
experience than anybody who's arrived
behind that desk since George HW Bush I
get that it's not a conventional
background but I don't think this is a
time for conventional backgrounds in
Washington right now you explain to
people what that experience means when
the rubber meets the road what how is
that going to help people in this
country it's the instinct to do the job
so whether we're talking about the
presidency or a job like governor or a
mayor you know there are three parts to
it it's bringing people together it's
implementing good policies and it's
capably running an administration all of
those have been missing right now in
Washington and I think you know American
mayors in cities of any size I think
represent one of the levels maybe the
only level of American government left
that's generally working well well we
all like to say that all politics are
local but the last time that a sitting
mayor was nominated for president to a
major party was 1812 yeah why should you
be different why may you be the outlier
that's doing better than the last time a
reality TV star
elected president right things are
changing tectonic Li in our country and
we can't just keep doing what we've been
doing we can't nibble around the edges
of a system that no longer works the
experience of the industrial Midwest is
exactly the kind of experience that
politics forgive me but here on the
coasts has been ignoring and especially
in my party that's coming a terrible
cost let's talk about something that
you're familiar with and obviously
that's time serving overseas in
Afghanistan you spent seven months there
what do you think of the president's
potential plan now of moving troops back
home well they come home now
we've got to get out of Afghanistan I
mean there are people who are now old
enough almost to be deployed who weren't
even born when 9/11 took place we've
also got to make sure that the way we do
it doesn't leave us vulnerable as some
Intel assessments have said we would be
to being attacked again within two years
if we allow terrorist networks to
develop in a failed state it's a good
sign that the Taliban is willing to talk
and if they're serious about putting
their weapons aside that could be a
pathway to peace but I'm a little
puzzled that we haven't had the Afghan
government itself that we recognize as
legitimate government at the table we've
got to make sure that they're involved
because any piece we come up with could
very quickly collapse if we don't have
them as a party those peace talks have
not included that it's shuttle diplomacy
right they go buddy they sit down with
the Taliban in Doha then you know we're
told that Khalil Asaad was was
conferring with the Afghan government
giving them I guess the heads up but
we've got to find a way to get them to
the table when you talk about nibbling
around the edges if you look at the
other Democrats who are running they're
not nibbling around the edges they're
talking about medicare-for-all some are
talking about getting rid of private
insurance so that's the coup that's the
competition you have so what is your
idea that it is so big that it that is
nobody would mistake it for nibbling
around the edges well first of all we've
got to repair our democracy the
Electoral College needs to go because
it's made our society less and less
democratic and we can talk about a lot
of different policy ideas and we'll on
everything from security to health care
but you know our party has this tendency
to lead with the policies go to the
14-point plan and give you the binders
and the powerpoints first we got to
explain our values and explain why
Democrats are committed to freedom to
democracy to security and that democracy
peace has to
be fixed before anything else will go
well in this country just to just
clarify what what John was asking about
do you support Medicare for all I do I
also think that on the road to get there
there are a lot of other things that are
not being talked about enough
Mayor Bloomberg who was likely join the
race says it would bankrupt this country
well it would bankrupt this country if
we didn't pay for it and right now in
Washington a lot of things are being
done that aren't paid for by the way my
generation is the one that's going to
face the bill for that so as somebody
who's god-willing planning to be here in
2050 for when I reach the current age of
the current president I care a lot about
making sure that anything we do is
sustainable but this is also the norm in
most developed countries so the idea
that it is radical or impossible to do
something that the citizens of most
Western countries already enjoy that
just doesn't add up to me if other
people can have that
why can't Americans have that too that's
a conversation that many in this country
are currently having right now including
potential products president hopefuls
thank you so much again our condolences
for the loss we appreciate thank you
shortest way home comes out on February
12th